following biden's disastrous afghanistan
withdrawal our allies are now worried
rightly so if they'll have u.s support
in their time of need today the white
house was forced to push back on chinese
propaganda attacking the u.s and taiwan
or what they call reunification here
with reaction to that is arkansas
senator tom cotton the chinese now have
aligned with russia they're providing
arms to iran
they have threatened our military bases
japan's military bases
we know that they are talking about
recognizing this new quote uh islamic
emirates of afghanistan as quickly as
possible
on top of that they're talking about
reunification which we both know would
be the takeover of taiwan
question tonight is senator what
we now have all of our enemies
seemingly trying to take advantage of
what's going on here how do we first
save the lives of americans in
afghanistan
yes sean you see the chinese propaganda
that's going to reverberate for years to
come
but the immediate priority as you say is
to get the americans trapped behind
taliban lines out of afghanistan joe
biden told a bald-faced law yesterday
when he said they planned for every
contingency they obviously did not
because there are 10 to 15 000 americans
behind taliban checkpoints my office has
been in direct contact with hundreds of
these people who have not heard from the
state department who cannot get to the
airport in kabul because the taliban
have checkpoints all over the roads and
control all access to it and joe biden's
administration won't even commit to stay
in afghanistan to secure that airport
for two more weeks to get all those
americans out and we're really now at
the mercy of how long the taliban is
willing to grant safe passage to
american citizens this is a fiasco it
has grave grave threats for our future
if there's a massive hostage crisis and
it really reveals joe biden's impotence
and incompetence to the whole world
it really is scary senator how can
happen is there anything you can do any
words you can say do you have any
confidence that we that we're going to
get our fellow americans the hell out of
there
sean i wish i could say that but based
on what i've seen from the biden
administration over the last two days as
my office has worked to provide
information to hundreds of americans the
state department has basically told us
that they don't want us to contact them
anymore just send them to a website so
they can fill out an e-form and
hopefully get a text message well what
if their phones aren't charged what if
the taliban cuts off sell cellular
service how are they supposed to get
through taliban lines to begin with joe
biden had no plan to evacuate 10 to 15
000 americans when he pulled out all of
our troops and our commander and shut
down bagram air base last month you
would think that the last thing you'd do
is turn out the lights on your
controlled air base and bring your
commander and his troops home after you
bring all the civilians home but right
now we have thousands of our countrymen
trapped behind enemy lines at risk of
being taken hostage by the taliban at
any time
senator unbelievable never of my
lifetime did i think this could happen
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else